[Music]
[Applause]
Ross Tucker Westwood W CBS Sports NFL
college football analyst and former NFL
offensive lineman the Ross Tucker
football podcast and you can find him on
social media at Ros Tucker NFL let me
start with the
Eagles this a big deal or no big
deal yeah well I think it is a big deal
because the expectations coming into the
year we're kind of Super Bowl or bust
right I mean last year I thought they
were the best team in the league they
played awesome in the first half of the
Super Bowl they weren't able to slow
down Mahomes in the second half they
lost the game golden opportunity to win
the whole thing and so as you know Dan
when you go there and you do that the
next year all that matters or all
anybody cares about is winning the whole
thing and they got a real uphill climb
now I mean they first of all they need
to win out just to be the number two
seed and to win the NFC East but the way
the ners are playing right now and the
ners are going to get a buy they would
play that game in San Francisco the ners
certainly appear to be the best team and
the better team than the Eagles right
now Niners might even be able to rest
their guys in week 18 feels like an
uphill climb I would say the one thing
in their favor Dan or maybe the two
things I still think the Eagles have a
very talented roster and and they would
have at least five more games between
now and an NFC Championship rematch
against San Francisco that's a lot of
time that's a lot of time for there to
be injuries or them to figure something
out or them to get back in a rhythm
offensively so the best thing they got
going is probably just the time between
now and a potential eventual rematch
okay what is the issue or issues with
the
Eagles several actually um number one
defensively they're just not as good as
they were last year they're clearly
worse at linebacker clearly worse at
safety and they kind of knew those two
coming into the year Dan like they lost
all those guys in free agency you know
they kind of knew that that was going to
be the case I'm not sure that they
realized there would be a drop off a
corner like this so you lose your
Nickelback of onon Maddox that hurts you
resign Bradberry and slle I think slle
is probably still playing at the level
he was last year bradberry's play has
slipped and dropped off so that hurt
slays out now after he got his knee
scoped so they have a lot of issues on
the back end and frankly they don't have
as much depth on the D line as they had
last year to be able to cycle through
those guys and keep them fresh and keep
the pressure on so I think the defensive
issues are primarily Personnel off
defensively they have the same guys it's
the same guys they're just not clicking
they settle for field goals they turn it
over I thought Herz got greedy a couple
times with both interceptions I mean you
know that first interception Dan they're
in Seahawks territory I think I I can't
remember if they're up by four or a
touchdown at that point it's first down
yeah it's first down in Seahawks
territory and you throw the ball to a
covered receiver who's at best your
fourth best receiver in quz Watkins very
disappointing if you're an Eagles fan
when I'm watching the Buffalo Bills game
and I realized that Josh Allen is not
going to be a big part of this he's not
going to throw very many passes now you
would do that sometimes if you're trying
to hide a quarterback this is Josh Allen
MVP candidate but if you're Dallas at
what point do you realize all they're
going to do is keep running the football
and then they can't stop the run and
then we go well is this the blueprint
for Buffalo we've been saying for years
get a good running game so Josh doesn't
have to do everything he didn't have to
do anything they ran the football and
they looked unbelievable let me start
with Buffalo is this sustainable with
James
Cook well I think certainly running the
ball more than they were earlier in the
season or with Ken dorsy is sustainable
I don't know that they'll put up that
many yards again or that dominant but it
is funny can you imagine if I came on
your show last Friday and said hey Dan
I'm going to predict right now um Josh
Allen throws for less than a 100 yards
and the Bills beat the Cowboys by three
touchdowns I mean you would have laughed
me off the show right um it's wild
absolutely wild that that game went down
the way it did I think it's gigantic
though I mean I did my Power Rankings
today on the Ross Tucker football
podcast I have the bills as the third
best team in the NFL right now and
people are G oh but Roth they're eight
and six and I don't care I go by what I
think would happen if they played at a
neutral site right now I think the
Niners are clearly the best team I think
the Ravens probably the second best team
but you look at the bills they should
have won that game in Philly they blew
that like five different ways when Josh
Allen was amazing they go to Kansas City
and win they Hammer the Cowboys they are
in the midst of playing top five teams
and they've been the better team
in these last three games as long as
they get into the tournament they're
going to be an absolute force to be
reckoned with explain to me a team can
be so good at home and then go on the
road and be so average and that's what
the Cowboys have been or maybe below
average when they go on the road how how
does why doesn't that team
travel well I you know they got blown
out by the Niners earlier in the year
the Niners have a really good team the
Bills game I mean they went to
Philadelphia and almost won that game on
the road I have no idea what happened in
the Arizona Cardinals game none how
that's even possible that they got blown
out by the Cardinals now they sat a
bunch of people including some offensive
lineman I'll say this though Dan because
I I know this look because I played in
Buffalo for three
years those guys didn't want to be there
man that they look like they did not
want to be there and here's the thing D
yeah but explain that to me how how does
a professional get to that I've seen it
before playing up there where when it's
really really cold in December you can
tell some of the other guys on their
team they're not happy that was like the
warmest December game in Buffalo ever
like it wasn't even that cold and yet
the if you watch the game I've never
seen so many guys that look like they
didn't even want to get off the Block
it's like they were glue on the and I
want to give the bills a lot of credit
they ran the ball down their throat all
of that stuff but the Cowboys were
sticking the blocks Like Glue they were
not getting off blocks I don't know if
it's because they had a let down after
the big win over the Eagles the previous
Sunday night or what but I thought it
was a noow by the Cowboys I thought they
laid an egg and I was not expecting that
we're talking to Ross Tucker the uh
Westwood W CBS Sports NFL college
football analyst and his podcast the
Ross Tucker football podcast you can
find him on social media at Ros Tucker
NFL you have Eagles in the Giants
Christmas Day
I think we thought that the U it that
you have the Giants and the uh Eagles
playing each other what two out of three
times or it's one week apart or two
weeks apart that we were gearing up for
this could be for the division or you
know the Giants and the Eagles and
battling for playoff spots here so you
got to sell that one a little bit don't
you with the Giants and uh Tommy DeVito
well I think that even would have been
able to sell it better if both teams had
better
performances this past weekend right I
mean even if the Eagles just win last
night then they're still in the mix for
the number one seed which they're really
not anymore and they're the front runner
in the NFC east and they still look like
they got you know they bounced back from
two tough games and for the Giants you
know there was a lot of excitement about
Tommy cutlets I prefer by the way
marinara momes I think that's a better
nickname um for Tommy DeVito but uh
there was excitement about the Giants
and and how they're finishing the season
then they went to New Orleans and that
game wasn't even remotely close I think
dble will have him in a better spot on
Christmas day but who knows Ross are you
gonna use the marinero
Mahomes I've been oh during the game for
sure okay yeah in fact I used it I think
I used it
Saturday um previewing the weekend or
something no on the uh Westwood One
preview yeah and my boss for Westwood
One Hoy dinov texted me and he said
marinara momes question mark exclam like
smiley face so when the boss gives you
the the smiley face Dan that's like
that's like the green light to use it a
couple times during the game all right
all right I'm Tommy gravy you know for
for those you know like Sunday gravy if
your wife happens to be Italian it's not
sauce it's gravy um I've heard uh I've
heard pass the passing
Pisano it feels like his 15 minutes is
is uh rapidly uh did you see Dan did you
see where tonight he was supposed to be
signing autographs at a pizzeria for 10
grand and they they promoted everything
but then the agent called and said well
now that he beat the Packers it's 20
grand so they had to cancel it because
they can't pay if that Pizzeria is
watching right now I'm two hours from
North Jersey I will drive there right
now for 1,500 bucks and an extra large
pepperoni 1500 bucks extra large
pepperoni I will drive two hours North
Jersey right now I promise okay so they
doubled the price because he had a big
win but did they come back down to earth
after he came back down to earth this
past weekend in New
Orleans I don't think so so here's the
thing like I get it if he has other
opport unities now for 20 grand and by
the way Tommy if you're listening I
would take advantage of all of these
opportunities because as Dan said this
might be your 15 minutes so this is like
free money but if he already committed
to that one you know everything was so
positive everything was great now you
have the loss and now you have this
family posting on like Facebook uh he's
not coming now he wants twice as much
money we don't have the money like now
now you're getting in a bad spot where
you're not everything's not good with
the family there no no I don't like this
at all all right before I let you go the
NFL with over punishing over finding
these defensive players the Steeler
defensive back now out for the year
multiple uh accuser
or multiple offender here violations
here Tom Brady said Gardner muu put his
receiver in a bad position um like it at
at some point what do you do for the
defense do you how do you teach defense
moving forward if you're in college or
certainly in the
NFL well I think both things can be true
like I think what Brady said about
Garder mshu putting Pitman In Harm's Way
and a hospital ball whatever you want to
call it that's that's a fact I mean
there's no question about that but that
doesn't mean that's how Damonte Kazi
needs to hit him right and unfortunately
Dan what I think you'll see even more of
is guys going lower and lower and lower
so we're going to start to see more and
more blown out knees more lower leg
issues because I I would mean some of
these guys are getting fine like 50
Grand I mean yeah but Pitman is going
low Ross it's already a low throw so
what's the the defensive back has to
basically say hey go ahead and catch it
you know if you catch it good for you
I'm not allowed to hit you I can't even
I can't even try to interrupt this play
that's not football well I think I think
you're I understand where you're coming
from that was a really ugly dangerous
hit and I think they just got to try to
teach him as much as possible to just go
for the ball and try to punch the ball
out I mean I think if you go in there
and you're swinging at the ball or
you're try to knock the ball out I think
you're probably safe if you're trying to
separate him from the ball with a big
hit then you're putting yourself in har
way I'm not saying I like it Dan I'm
just telling you that's why they're
doing it they're trying to eliminate
ugly collisions like that you have your
uh helmets from your former team which
one do you look best in like if you go
get one of those off of the trophy case
do they still fit they do fit and it's
crazy how heavy they are would you would
you go get one sure yeah which one you
want me to get I got two different
Redskins ones I got a Cowboys a
Princeton a Patriots a bills which one
do you think you look
you know what the Cowboys is cool but I
like the old school Redskins one okay
I'm going to put that one on all right
all right Ross Tucker former offensive
lineman one of the larger heads in NFL
history they used to try to get me to do
like the new helmet but I have short
arms Dan yeah so the newer helmet was
lighter and my first move when I went up
to a linebacker was just a headbutt him
I was like I don't want a lighter give
me the heaviest helmet you have what are
you you talking about oh it's a little
stiff okay all right man wow you look
imagine this coming at you Whoa man
imagine that whoa it's a good thing
there's a TV monitor in between us zoom
in next time I come up there I'll take
on all four donets at one time do you
think you could worried about
Marvin all four all four you you could
beat up all four danut at the same time
you know what's weird I've lost 75 lbs
and I don't think my head's gotten any
smaller because this is like this is
hurting my forehead like I'm getting a
headache like this is not good how did I
wear this for like three and four hours
at a time he is going to be with you on
Christmas day it'll be the Giants and
the Eagles 4:30 Eastern kick off on
Westwood one man you are scary look at
you
Reggie White would want nothing to do
with you hey remember this Dan Bruce
Smith would only have 99 sacks if it
wasn't for me and how many did you end
up with
[Laughter]
200 oh thank you bud Merry Christmas to
you thank you Ross that's uh rossington
Tucker always good to talk to he
knucklehead I saw all those helmets I
thought you know what let me see if he
can put one on yes tdd I'm conc about
him being able to get that off now to
shove it on I'm not concerned about him
getting it off I was concerned about him
getting it on we should have tried to
have him get it off on Zoom that
should maybe we can we punch it back up
maybe the big German uh is oh you got
the helmet off okay
yay he did
it all right we're back after this